a mind frame we'll find you oh
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by post Malone he's
an artist we sat down with some five and
a half years ago and in the time since
he's just gone on to smash billboard and
streaming records one of the highest
selling most decorated musicians of the
last decade he also has a brand new
long-awaited album on the way 12 karat
toothache which is coming soon and I for
one can't wait post Malone welcome back
to the show sir thanks for having me
before we get started I'm curious have
you been experimenting with hot sauce at
all since we saw you last do fans ever
bring up your OG hot ones interview in
the wild it's like one of the top five
biggest episodes you've ever done did
you guys send me a habanero one we
probably did and I think you signed it
but I wanted to taste it so bad so I
cracked it I was just like yeah I got it
and then I drink it straight but it
looks like the lineup has changed a
little bit here on season 18 it is it's
actually a brand new lineup and here's
kind of a fun fact that this is the very
first time that I'm taking on this
lineup and it's right along with you
post Malone I wouldn't have it any other
way
I don't answer
[Music]
thank you
classic garlic Fresno I see we've gone
tendy this time for you posty I love you
I love you guys
all right
diving in
[Music]
this is delicious
the spice
I'm impervious no problem yeah there's
no problem
it's got a little afterburn but other
than that yeah you know it's nice
it says we mentioned up top you have
your Ford Studio albums on the way and I
think it's worth mentioning that your
first three are something like combined
18 times Platinum with beerbongs and
Bentleys and Hollywood's bleeding each
being number one records respectively
you had a recent interview with
billboard where you said I don't need a
number one that doesn't matter to me no
more and at a point it did I didn't know
that you said 18 times that's pretty
[ __ ] awesome that's a lot that's so
cool thank you Sean your shot is the
coolest guy in the [ __ ] world
um but there was a moment to where I
lost my passion to make music
you know it's like
it becomes a job I was just a kid you
know and making music and I had all
these songs and everything but
it became a job you know with
labels and touring and everything and it
gets so hard to actually focus on why
you're there you know what I mean it
used to be like okay we get in the
studio and be like let's make hits let's
bring a bunch of producers and let's
bring a bunch of different artists in
but
um on this record there's only a couple
couple producers couple artists and
um I just want to make I just want to
make sure finally now that I'm back it
feels like I I was a uh in a cocoon and
now I'm a beautiful butterfly we're
seeing the metamorphosis happen right
before and now I'm here
you know what I mean but yeah I'm so
excited I'm so excited it's my favorite
piece of work that we've ever done so
is mezcal like tequila
oh does this have booze in it yeah
really messed up a bit messed up
[Music]
Sean that's good
hitting two for two so far that's good
there we go
do I do I get to take some of these home
you get to actually take all of them
home
that's good job oh my God and you know
what if you want me to sign another one
I got you I got you yes sir
so between Stone Cold riding ATVs around
Broken Skull and John Mayer ditching
West Hollywood from Montana I'm
fascinated by guests who've taken on a
more secluded lifestyle sure have you
had any close encounters with Wildlife
since moving to the seven acre compound
in the backcountry mountains of Utah
um there is a big mama cougar that runs
around and so we have dogs and stuff and
a cat
um we built like it's like a big gate
fence it's supposed to keep all the
wildlife out but somehow this big cougar
keeps getting it She's Crafty very
crafty also there was an alien there
what not like a physical alien but like
a ball I think it was an alien or a
ghost we caught on the infrared camera
does alien count his Wildlife very wild
extreme Wildlife I think I don't know
demons count as wildlife
or aliens but you know I don't know it
was so cool we saw it so we got cameras
all around the whole place and
um
just this big orb I'd say like like if
you take sauron's eye so it starts
forming the shape of like sauron's eye
and goes under this door
and uh I don't know what that was either
I don't know if that counts yeah between
that and the cougar it sounds like you
got your hands well yeah I don't I'm
scared it's like it's like [ __ ] Dark
Souls whenever I go outside
it's like Elden ring whenever it goes I
don't know what the hell I'm gonna find
out
foreign
this one is the adobo Loco okay Island
wing sauce
[Music]
it does get hotter yeah that's how the
show is formatted that's how it goes
that is how it goes
[Music]
coming through
yeah I tell you what my shits are gonna
be crazy
can you give me a beat that the first
time you heard it you knew that it would
be a post Malone Stadium Anthem and then
can you give me another one that maybe
you didn't fully understand or Vibe with
at first that turned out to be a massive
hit for you I feel like I knew I knew
congratulations was gonna be big but
that's just because the genius cuevo is
in the room I was like yo quit what do
you think about this he's like this [ __ ]
is crazy in Metro too
um I don't know maybe psycho I didn't
think it was gonna be as big as it was
or candy paint even because I moved that
too I didn't I was like okay I like this
song because I've always been
a fan of
major chords and like happy music but
like you know talking your [ __ ] at the
same time I think that's a perfect
balance and it's very tongue-in-cheek
and it's very you know
I love that I think it's probably psycho
I didn't know that people would like it
that much I was like okay yeah [ __ ] yeah
okay thank you so much
it's not that bad there we go yeah I
think it actually is not quite as spicy
as three I felt like I remember you
played some psychological games with us
yeah this is delicious but it's not as
hot exactly
so I'm always fascinated by what goes
into making an athlete's signature shoe
and the world of a musician what are the
conversations like when you're tricking
out a custom guitar deciding which
instruments you're going to bring with
you on tour
I went to there's a place called
Carter's in Nashville they had this
1938 Martin and it was owned by a guy I
think his name was like hobo bill or
something like something crazy it had
his songs in the guitar case and a
rattlesnake tale inside of it I got two
guitars that are my favorite guitars
Sunburst Les Paul that I played on the
Nirvana thing I'm the shittiest guitar
player and it makes me feel like I'm the
best in the world and uh Willie Nelson's
guitar is so cool it's got a big hole in
it it looks like he punched it I don't
know I'm more of a road worn I like the
yeah you like the story the bad story
yeah it's definitely been through some
[ __ ] and um this guitar has been through
some [ __ ] this dude killed a rattlesnake
and threw this tail in there I was like
this is crazy
I love that are you ready to move on
here to the halfway point okay this is
the sauce leopard seventh Reaper
and there is some Carolina Reaper in
this one some tomato some garlic some
Reaper
that smells
like death okay
it tastes delicious but it's hot it's
definitely definitely buffing it up
inside it's stoking the flame yeah
hey that's pretty good so far are we
five for five all right yeah we're five
for five that's what I'm talking about
yep all right posties you may recall we
have recurring segment on our show
called explain that gram we're gonna do
a deep dive in our guessing interesting
pictures that need more contact so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story okay
that guy's cool
further explanation sure and then I'm
also curious you know as uh as somebody
who's been a video game junkie your
whole life turned musician how important
is music to the gaming experience for
you have you played out
there has been times in that game I I
turned the music all the way off because
it is insane it's like literally like
choirs like not not of angels of demons
and yeah like we're gonna [ __ ] you up
there's no way you live and after a
fight I have to like I'm like shaking
like this so I have to walk outside and
smoke and I'm like I need to decompress
and like do all this [ __ ] but music is
very important however the video games
whenever Skyrim came out the theme song
gave me chills as a kid and there's so
much some of the best music comes from
video games there's like such epic songs
like Zelda has a Crazy soundtrack uh
Elder Scrolls has a Crazy soundtrack all
this like Mario there's not there's yeah
there's no one in the world that doesn't
know the Mario song it's so cool it's
like the Star Wars It's like Star Wars
songs and the Lord of the Rings songs
it's just they're Timeless pieces that
super nostalgic on you know watching it
you know it's super cool
this
I needed to get my kill death ratio up
so I said what's gonna get what's gonna
give me the edge I said put some damn
night vision goggles on and see what's
going on
um no yeah if I turn those on right
there in that picture I would probably
go black you ever seen Step Brothers
where they're like yeah
we got him one more 40.
but that was a fun night and I took it
was just for the picture
I played one game
[Music]
okay
yeah
the ghost pepper really
shines through in that one
oh my God
[Music]
hot and Saucy hot and Saucy like you
shot oh
I'll take it I'll take it I'll take what
I can get it
now you say it back to me hey hot and
sauce thank you Stephen thank you Saucy
all day all day thank you sir
totally original compliment and you I
didn't tell you special for you Taylor
Made it for you it's perfect and I meant
it I meant every word
honestly it's an assault on your tongue
it's gone now yeah we're back we're back
it's gone now we're over pain it came
and went
we turn the page on it yeah it's
delicious it's absolutely delicious six
for six six for six sure oh there we go
some pretty talk about resisting
pressure to say jam-pack an album with
20 or 25 tracks very much so in what
ways do you think the economics of the
music industry influences the way that
music is put out these days
I guess right now I suppose the
algorithm is set up for
what the hell was that noise
I sound like Predator from uh AVP or
something
the the format right now I guess it's
the more songs you have the more you're
gonna stream it's kind of like it's
almost like an accuracy by volume
yeah because you could throw 20 songs or
you could throw 20
Blobs of goop at the wall one of them's
gonna stick
maybe more than one is gonna stick but
I think what's interesting about this
album is it's 42 minutes 14 songs it's a
story and I think more so than anything
I've made before it's a living breathing
entity almost
I'm so excited
I'm so pumped
I love that all right Posey you're ready
to move on Seventh sauce you're doing
great so far okay this one is the ha low
ghee
[Music]
tierfing's curse
[Music]
it's a sleeper yeah
I don't feel it there we go I don't feel
it yeah let's get out it's not that bad
it is delicious
seven for seven then I'd have to say
seven for seven there we go
first test drive on the new lineup could
not be going better
I'm passing it to you I'm passing it
you look like Mages dueling
can you photoshop not Photoshop nuts
also make me eight feet tall
all right we'll take a swing at that
here we go tall post
so we had Dave Grohl on the show he
talked about how he pulled a muscle in
his hand playing Message in a Bottle by
the police and you're a distinguished
cover man yourself what do you learn
from performing the music of other
greats like Bob Dylan or Darius Rucker
or Nirvana
everything that I want to do musically
Jesus yeah it's there
it's still reminding me it's reminding
me I think it heard you yeah exactly
exactly that's the whole thing he talks
that's not hot but it'd be like
these are people that I've looked up to
for so long and being able to hear that
Eden [ __ ] it up it feels really good
sting is nuts yeah he's a nut
like the [ __ ] he does is like insane and
I I I he I he's epic and I watched the
show I don't remember what the only
murders in the building was staying in
there and I thought that was great too
that's so Random what's wrong with me
this sauce is hacking my brain man it's
in the Mainframe
[Music]
just a bomb it's the bomb
rip to us oh my God
[Music]
instant
thank you
[Music]
wow wow
not easy for me either that's such a
joke yeah
like
oh my God no no it's not hot it's easy
it's easy stop dude no problem no
problem no problem are you having a
problem I'm having no problems
[Music]
I know I know
[Music]
not hot I just wanted it not hot
can you talk me through the process of
securing a PSA 10 Magic the Gathering
card valued at close to a million
dollars like what is the hunt like how
challenging how difficult is the hunt
for a black lotus and why does that card
why does it have Holy Grail status to
you
what
[Music]
9.5 Alpha Black Lotus printed in 1993
signed by Chris Rush it's just the Holy
Grail of Magic Gathering which is the
best game ever created
foreign
[Music]
would you say is the biggest
misconception about magic the Gathering
and the people who play it
you know it might be conceived as like
nerdy
um and I'm a [ __ ] nerd and I'm so
damn happy to be a nerd
um
I don't spend I used to but I don't
do bottle service anymore I don't go to
strip club I
just sit in my room and play with cards
all day
but um it's not bad it's pretty normal
sauce type of stuff
[Music]
cheers cheers at home
if you own this hot sauce take some with
us
that's a big bite well mistake mistake
alert
you know what it can't be it can't be
worse than the last one though it can't
be worse than the last one this one like
a really spicy curry or something it
tastes like sausage yeah it tastes like
a bratwurst yeah
so I know that you long have been
obsessed with the metaphysical and then
you even appeared in that ghost
adventure show where you explored a meat
packing
we explode a meat packing plant in
Arizona meat packing plant in Arizona
can you give me like a ghost hunting
starter pack like if I were to go hit
the streets like what did some with some
equipment that I need
a mind frame
we'll find you oh
[Music]
Sean I'm telling you I'm telling you is
it worse than you remember you got tough
gig yeah
it's very worse than ever
[Music]
guys do I have any boogies you're all
good you're clean you're clean there's
you need a EMF detector it measures like
and all of this stuff Sean Evans is just
a legend yeah right
like I like you know what it's fun like
whatever who knows but sometimes it's
just fun to go on that ride there's
something going on yeah there's
definitely something going on that we
don't know about
um
but EMF detector
a voice recorder
preferably analog
okay I'll put the analog
um
[Music]
camera with infrared
or night shot
and then you're good to go Sean Evans we
can go wherever the hell you want [ __ ]
yeah all right we can go next time next
time next time we'll go to your buddy's
house let's go okay we'll go to Texas
we'll do this yep in Texas and there
will definitely be demons there
in the toilet all right
[Laughter]
you're the boss Sean Evans I'll do
whatever you tell me
when
has the last time
you've heard someone say FML
[ __ ] my life uh probably in 2015 or
something do you remember that
I gotta bring it back and now it's kind
of a good time FML
you hit the dab at the same time that's
perfect
oh how much did you put on I'd give it a
nice little smattering okay so you
smatter it I smattered it
Evans please no it's not actually not
hot let's go it's actually not hot
[Music]
all right post Malone you have now
conquered the wings of death for a
second time and to close things out we
really want to put the two of us to the
test with a little quick last dab beer
pong we're gonna put one cup on your
side one cup on my side over here
I am going to I don't know if you
remember these these
you remember yeah I remember
that little sudden death beer pong game
okay you go ahead and go no you go first
all right all right
those glasses are mad cool too you
remember these yes sir those aren't the
same ones not the same not the same
oh
now you gotta dance
[ __ ] my life [ __ ] my life [ __ ] my life
that's cool that's cool right
[Music]
last ABS standoff
[Music]
FML everybody all around
post Malone Sean Adam taking on the
wings of death conquering winning in
beer pong
did you drink it all that guy yeah
you're such a legend let's go down now
post Malone
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
I have an album coming out soon it's
called 12 karat toothache it's got uh 14
very amazing songs on it I'm the
happiest I've ever been thank you for
waiting for me just be as good as you
can and don't be a [ __ ] I love you
very much this is Sean Evans
the best to ever [ __ ] do it right
here
um
um finding his cameras yeah they're
everywhere
but let's party
[Applause]
I'm so heavy dude I'm so happy to be
back I'm so happy to be here like this
is the best show
ever you are the best host you are
genuinely the best host because you are
such a beautiful person man like it's
it's it's mind-blowing how great you are
give me a hugs buddy I love you I love
you too you're the best wow
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's video
the season 18 sauces they're here and
you know what that means Dom box me so
is the big box the season 18 hot ones
box is now available at heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands
and all of the season 18 sauces
delivered straight to your door and one
convenient box don't forget to be
careful around the eyes
[Music]